[Musique]
c'est certainement l'un des meilleurs
sites au monde pour les observer on va
prendre notre temps et on va essayer de
s'approcher au plus près ce matin au
large du Gabon Damien Viessmann
accompagne un groupe de touristes
parisiens à la recherche de baleines à
bosse
[Musique]
il n'a fallu que 10 minutes pour la
trouver
la première est juste là
à quelques mètres du bateau
c'est tellement impressionnant que
j'arrive même pas à réaliser que je les
vois en fait
quels sont tout autour de nous c'est
vraiment c'est absolument incroyable
c'est majestueux c'est en fait le c'est
tellement immense ça se trouve que c'est
super gracieux la manière dont ça se
déplace
mère et fils attendez ce voyage depuis
des années et le spectacle est loin
d'être terminé
on n'a pas assez d'une vie pour pour
tout voir finalement et
c'est un camion de 30 tonnes qui sort de
l'eau qui retombe avec un bruit
assourdissant
donc oui ça donne des frissons à chaque
fois on s'en lasse pas
pour aller au bout de l'expérience et
comme la mer est calme le guide Franco
gabonais autorise même ses clients à
plonger avec les baleines gardez à
l'esprit c'est un animal sauvage c'est
un comportement imprévisible donc une
fois que vous êtes dans l'eau évitez des
gestes brusques voilà laissez-vous
porter allez-y
les plus courageux se jettent à l'eau et
les voici aux côtés de l'un des plus
grands mammifères au monde 15 mètres de
long
au champ en vous temps
[Musique]
dans l'eau il faut vite regarder parce
que tu vois juste la queue qui dépasse
et puis après elles sont déjà partis
chaque été le Gabon abrite l'une des
plus grandes populations de baleines à
bosse
au mois de juin elles sont des milliers
à quitter l'Antarctique direction les
eaux chaudes des côtes africaines les
États se s'installent au large de
Madagascar et du Gabon pour se
reproduire puis repartent en septembre
avec leur petit
pour préserver ces animaux le pays a mis
en place 20 zones maritimes protégées
par des ecoges
oui non will jaune est responsable du
plus grand parc marin situé au sud du
Gabon
jusqu'à la frontière congolaise
Régis à droite lance qui à gauche
mission du jour vérifier qu'il n'y a pas
d'intrus dans la réserve
et recenser les baleines moi le point
GPS
pour mieux protéger un animal la
première chose c'est de savoir combien
ils sont si on sait le nombre
d'individus qui a dans nos a protégés on
peut aisement prendre des mesures
grâce aux données qu'il récoltent les
autorités pourront améliorer leur
programme de protection de la faune
marine
c'est pas trop où il permet aussi
d'analyser le comportement des baleines
qui n'ont pas fini de les surprendre on
dit sur la bureau
pendant plusieurs minutes l'animal
tourne autour du bateau
sors sa tête de l'eau et prend la pause
la pluie
[Rires]
[Musique]
le Gabon s'est fixé un objectif
agrandir les réserves naturelles marines
et protéger intégralement 30% de ses
eaux d'ici 10 ans